do you write out all the key beats
before you start your script
i've done both so i i have occasionally
i mean
more times than not done a beat sheet or
an outlet full flesh outline um
and then there have been there's more
rare times where i just run with it
because the idea is just pouring out of
me and i've got the idea
but it's not the best to do that that
has not worked the best for me the
outline
is always like you when you have a
fleshed-out outline you know exactly
where you're headed and if you spend a
little bit more time
on that outline and really like let let
yourself know what this what's going on
with each of these characters and where
they're headed
my scripts will just like fly to the
finish line when i have a nice outline
uh to accompany it but
sometimes you just have that idea and
you just see it really clearly and
you're like let's rock and roll i can do
this and
i do feel when you do that you have to
go back and edit a little bit more and
tighten things up and clarify things
because you know your mind is trying to
just
race this whole idea to the page um
and then also maybe you're just going to
write a certain portion of the script
you know and then you're going to stop
and be like all right i'm kind of at a
set a dead end here
let's go ahead and just outline you can
outline at any point you don't have to
start with the outline you can
start writing what you see clearly and
then do your outline from there and
maybe go back and start editing like
okay i need this character to actually
start having this
this journey closer to the beginning or
you know whatever it is you're gonna do
um but i like both i think the outline
is really fun because it's uh
you get to get all the like the meaty
yummy bits it's basically all the treats
are out there on the screen so you're
just you're just living in this world of
treats in your story
and then when you're actually scripting
you're all right you're living in
okay so my character i need to have this
conversation but
it's not the most fun you know you want
to get to the like the treat part of the
the script um so yeah i like either one
right and you're doing all of this on a
computer you're not doing it longhand
yeah i do everything like i essentially
constantly have pages open on my
constantly just pages and like i even
have one document that's just open
every single day because i just keep
adding new ideas to it
so sometimes if it's getting too muddled
i'll do a page break and like all right
new idea blah blah blah blah
and that's what i go back and i'll like
scan through it if i'm having a writer's
block type of a day
like what did i think of like seven
months ago and i kind of go back up and
i'm like oh that was a good idea i
should have flushed
flush that out a bit more so yeah do you
really struggle
with writer's block or changing your
mind
changing my mind in what capacity in
terms of maybe you you decide oh i think
i want this character to do this because
i see you just having a ton of ideas
like it's a well that i don't know
that's just i mean that's what it feels
like it feels like i'll never i won't
even have enough time on this earth to
tell all the stories i'd love to tell
um but i am going to try and uh
as far as changing my mind i mean
you know sometimes when you get an idea
i feel like you feel pretty strong like
you have a few
core things that you feel strongly you
know kind of a bit
what's going on with your character at
least you you kind of know what you can
recognize within them
you know a little bit about what the
struggle is going to be and maybe you
have something fun in there that you
that's what was the uh
the inciting event of your story and so
from those little pieces
you kind of know what's what's going on
so changing your mind after you've
seen the idea in your head happens
uh not as frequently for me but it will
happen if i get feedback and i'm like oh
oh absolutely this could be better this
way and then that then that's no problem
at all okay
if this is going to be better let's run
with it in that direction um
the changing of them i don't think i
changed my mind too much and maybe i
could change my mind a little bit more
often in the in the creation process
because
just because i see something clearly on
day one doesn't mean that that's the
end-all be-all
i need to be malleable constantly the
story could can be changing i need to be
influenced by things i see all
throughout the day people out on the
street everything
and trying to create the most nuanced
and interesting detail-rich characters
out there you know you don't want to
just
see all the same old stuff constantly so
um yeah
i think actually i could change my mind
a little bit more that would be helpful
do you pick up on what you see in terms
of infusing that into a character
constantly absolutely it's my greatest
day if i can go out and see someone
doing something a little bit interesting
i'm like
interesting and then i mean that's an
interesting character either or
we all as as just human beings have
experiences that we're probably not even
thinking about
like i was i was thinking to myself i
was reading a really interesting
creepypasta
it ended up being kind of you know like
a kind of boilerplate story but i still
really enjoyed myself
but i liked the story even though it was
boilerplate because it was so
detail-rich it was about this uh girl
and uh you know
just kind of like her she didn't have
any friends in the town she makes this
one friend and it was all the little
creepy things they got into into in that
small town they like broke into some
house somewhere
um you know because there was some
folklore in the house um and it wasn't
exactly that the story was so unique it
was the details that she was including
she was
talking about these younger brothers
that were giving them a hard time and
how they were
scaring them at night one night when
they were watching a horror film and it
was those
rich details and like the pink converses
that the one girl was wearing and you're
like
oh yeah i remember that when i was a kid
like one of my friends got the gold
sicconi's and we got into a fight
because i didn't have the gold zucconi
you know what i mean and like details
like that really
just bring you to another place and
those are the details that i'm always
like trying to rev up in my brain
so recently i was thinking like okay
let's give myself a challenge of
what's something kind of interesting
that i used to do
at a younger age at a completely
different point in my life and maybe
write a short story based on that and
just like confuse it with all these rich
details that are going to help
transport the reader to that time in
their life and maybe like remind them of
something that they did
hopefully without the ghosts because i'm
probably going to have some supernatural
elements
in this one have you always been
attracted to
supernatural ghost switches i was
terrified
i couldn't even watch trailers like i
remember being
maybe 14 or so something along those
lines
and there was a movie trailer for a
horror film
that came on tv and i turned to my
grandma and i was like they shouldn't
even allow
trailers like that to be out on tv
they're terrifying like i was too afraid
to watch something that was available
for cable i mean they let in they
hardly let anything on cable um and now
i'm like the scarier the better like how
can we
how can i scare people even more i mean
that's my goal i want to scare people
like
deeply right and i keep bringing up the
exorcist it's gonna be one of these
things that i'm
not gonna be able to bring up anymore
because i sometimes get focused on
topics but
the great thing about the film was that
there was so much that wasn't
yes there were gory scenes and there was
the the vomit and all these different
things
but so much of it was this this
weird ominous force that
they didn't really need all of that to
scare you oh absolutely
i mean that that to me that's where the
terror
lives once you snap that cord and reveal
what it is that's been haunting or you
know what the truth is you have to give
the explanation
at some point in time most likely i mean
that's where you're going to defuse all
of your attention
you lit we live and and and just
play in the in the field of growing this
tension
and i hope to become a better
uh mystery tension suspense writer
if i should be so lucky you know to keep
trying and trying to make make something
really scary
um i was just watching something
that what was it oh is it is it okay if
i say movie names oh sure is it all
right
um so where was watch aaron and i were
looking for a movie recommendation so we
texted our friend and he said oh you
should watch
his house and i had watched his house
already i watched it kind of in the
afternoon one day when i was looking for
inspiration
and it is a really good movie i loved it
i thought it was fantastic
um really really good movie but i didn't
find it to be that scary
right and so my friend's like what what
do you think is scary and i was like
i haven't nothing has scared me nothing
has scared me in a really long time
um and then of course i had to hearken
back to when i did see hereditary which
was the
last time i was terrified absolutely
terrified
out of my wits couldn't believe that i
had watched that paid a movie ticket to
see that i mean i'm happy now because it
was really like
whoa i can't believe that um but that
was the last really truly scary thing i
had ever seen
and um you know that's just where where
a lot of like
my ins my hope as a writer comes from i
see i want i want to be scared so that i
can then kind of
understand what tools are required to to
give that thrill to somebody else
and i can only really do it if if i kind
of can see
something to build off of or to try and
build off of if i
could be so lucky to make something like
hereditary although a little bit gory
but
still still very creepy yeah it was so
scary but it was also
slow moving and and very quiet at times
and it really held your attention
exactly i mean that's that is where it
all lives like ah
just wondering what's in the shadows
wondering what's in the air around you
in those types of films
that's it that's what you need so how do
you create that that's really the
question
and that's that's something i'm current
i'm
trying to to figure out trying to share
i think i have like a little bit of an
idea but i'm excited to see what future
victoria
comes up with because i think i think
i'm like working at a
i'm working at a regular enough pace
where i'm like starting to really
sharpen things
really isolate how to make things scary
and really build an atmosphere that's
going to be
filled with tension is it harder for you
to write character or plot
character i think character
i think it's character because
how do we ever know all the different
levels and nuances
nuance nuances uh of a person you know
what i mean and how can i
write like make that into words so that
then the actor can take it and
breathe their life into it to me that's
far
more challenging to to try and tackle
you know there's just so so much of a
vast world to play with
with character um i do hope to be to
just
get better and better at that craft i
love
love i live and play in creating the
plot like that's for me like and this is
it and this is how it has to be and this
is like and you know and then and
shaping that world and
and building it and really like i said
playing like you're you it's nothing yet
you know you get to play
and create whatever you want um people
are a little bit different characters
are different because you want people to
like your characters to some degree not
every character is going to be likable
but there needs to be something that
makes someone want to watch your
character at the very least
and that to me is like okay how do i
make someone who's
they don't have to be likable but they
need to be interesting to watch
um and then how do i make them you know
not just be me
like i don't want it to just always be
version i mean i guess it's always going
to be a version of myself and all these
characters because that's the person i
know the most
um but i think you get that by listening
you can get better at your character
work by listening to your friends just
listen to them listen to what's going on
with them listen to their family stories
listen to their struggles and their
their stresses and you can really start
to understand like how to create
different levels of characters there
you